this question was well done because it
was a fairly straightforward
substitution everything looked okay and
you guys to your credit were really good
at managing your algebra quite carefully
in there so it comes up on that alright
let's get to the volume so here's Part D
now there are a couple of critical
places where people fell down here okay
firstly some people still are forming
the wrong integrand and most of that
comes out from your diagram was crummy
so you didn't know how stuff was related
to itself okay you're like I subtracted
this from that instead of that from this
so that was a point of error secondly
when you went from PR having everything
in terms of white to here and then
thirdly to here you tripped yourself up
on your algebra so what you did well in
the previous question you sort of
struggled here when you were collecting
like terms something as simple as
collecting like terms you would have
only lost one mark because it was one
error but that was a common place where
people fell down okay 11.30 was the
volume we were looking for so the
integration once you got that most
people were very successful with that
because there's a straight Ford
polynomial okay let's move over to the
recurrence relation now this is three
marks the majority of people were
successful in the vast majority people
almost everyone was successful in
getting the first mark which was doing
the integration by parts bit right but
then people struggled to progress past
that now when you have a look at the
result there the key to working out how
to get from this line here which is
where it's just integration by parts to
the the subsequent lines the key really
is to look super carefully at where
you're supposed to get to and do all of
your algebraic manipulation in order to
get you there
that's what you had to do okay so let's
have a just quickly have a look I'll get
these areas back out of the way look at
what's happening look at how I approach
this and why I have done them scuse me
why I've manipulated the expressions in
the way that I did okay
for example a huge number of students
didn't even think to do this
okay what is this a useful thing why
have I inserted a 1 minus X into them
thank you
yeah very good it's got to interact with
this guy over here right so we've seen
this before 1 minus X this is like
intrigue trig identities you have to put
something in and take it out which is
not obvious but here the clue is this
guy you have to get the 1 minus X in
there and it's not there like here until
you one take away one take away X okay
so that was the first thing that many
students forgot and then secondly once
I've got them in this position right
that's why you can separate it out and
get your to your I of this and I have
that okay once people if people got to
their they were pretty successful
afterwards but I think it was that
critical spot in the middle which is the
hardest part and then after they you
just had to do a bit of um manipulation
okay any questions on that one now is
question 11 overall well done let's have
a look at the graph so you'll need to
turn back to the pages that have these
graphs so come back to your multiple
choice page and let's have a look at
these four guys here okay now let me
just overall say I was really happy with
how most of this wind okay so big thumbs
up to you this one was pretty
straightforward I think most of the
areas that people will have a look at
here it'll be like oh man I knew that
it's not that hard the absolute value it
was straight for I think almost everyone
got that one right so thumbs up when you
come over to here it's time to get a bit
more challenging but most people still
got a pretty good idea okay now the most
common error there were two common
errors okay the first corner is people
saw Y squared and they said oh it's all
positive okay so they would have given
me this graph but only the top half
right they didn't realize well it's Y
squared so that means you can supply
negative values in it's reflected in the
same way that y equals x squared is
reflected horizontally this guy is
reflected vertically okay that was the
first common error the second common era
was the
can anyone guess it was the root three
it was the scale okay so you can see I
was fairly lenient with this section of
the graph over here okay because you
don't have that much information about
what the numbers are if your graph you
know if it looks something like this
rather than what I've got I sort of gave
you a pass on that and I was looking for
the general shape however I would point
out important values because it's y
squared equals f of X you've got one two
three places on the y equals one line I
this is why you were given the y equals
one line right because one squared is
still one right so you should have
points of intersection there I know it's
hard to get so if you were close I gave
you that but I'm some people just sort
of ignored it didn't even realize that
was important okay so yeah there's those
three coordinates all right over the
page okay let me reverse the question
what do you think was the most common
thing to get wrong here
scale again now there was a bit of a
clue oh and I actually when we were
going through the the composition of
this paper we were debating over whether
we should do this
so you'll notice just look at one and
two parts one or two and then look at
three and four right now the the scale
the grass themselves the axes give you a
clue they say hey look you're gonna need
you're gonna need all this space up here
so um unfortunately a lot of people had
the right idea but they put their nine
about there right they only made it
twice as high like if you've got a scale
provided to you you must use it you must
use it so um that clearly will be
something like six it's not the right
value okay I wasn't too worried about
the curvature at these points but you
should have had something nice and
smooth there because if you have a look
the way I reasoned this by the way a lot
of people who drew cusps there though
our reason is the regional function
clearly is a polynomial of some kind
and it's clearly a polynomial because
you can see by the curvature well if you
take a polynomial and you square the
whole thing what kind of family of
functions are you still in you're still
in polynomials so you still have all of
these these smooth things it's not like
the absolute value which is why where
you get the sharp points all right and
then e to the FX general shape was done
out stead
well so thumbs up you already noticed
that scale was a problem the other
common theme was that several people
didn't put it in asymptotes or they
didn't even realize are there's going to
be an asymptote
some people's graphs went underneath the
axis this is e to the power of something
it doesn't matter what the something is
that you supplied to there you'll never
get a negative number so that's why the
whole graph should reside above the
y-axis and you should have had the
question itself even told you please
provide the asymptotes in there and you
should have said the equation two but
how is it leaning on that okay so those
are the graphs let's move into Part B so
come back to where you've got your long
response questions short responses long
ones papi was done great I generally
think in terms of errors like silly
errors don't understand areas I think
these are facepalm errors most of the
ones I was looking at people just like
oh I wanna do that for okay so I think
once you see your error you know what
you've done wrong but if you would like
me to clarify further let me go turning
over the page on the question paper when
you look at Part C I firmly believe that
large parts of the extension to course
just look scary but they aren't scary
this is one of the simplest questions
one of the easiest three marks in the
entire paper you're looking at your life
holy cow like you know this is one of
the questions I pull out to show you
like to nuisance like I have to do that
but if you look carefully no I've given
you a whole bunch of diagrams here to
help you form the the area and therefore
the volume it's a simple simple integral
so 2/3 I was very happy where people got
there okay